were the Nazis left-wing that's a good
question
it depends see the problem with any
question that says is a B is a
equivalent to B is that it depends on
how you define a and B right and I'm not
trying to weasel out of the question I'm
very very serious about that the Nazis
regarded themselves as National
Socialists you know so they weren't
free-market capitalist slits se so they
certainly weren't right-wingers in the
way that free-market capitalists are
right wingers even though they're
probably more centrist they differed
from the International Socialists which
were the Marxists because they were much
more concerned with national identity
and racial identity and to the degree
that you regard nationalism and racial
identity as primarily right-wing views
then the Nazis would have been
right-wing so let's say that they maybe
they pulled from the worst of both
extreme something like that but I do
think it's reasonable to note that their
extreme nationalism and ethnocentrism
and racial identity probably has more in
common with the radical right that it
does with the radical left which tends
to be utopian Universal so one of the
things I thought would be an interesting
research project would be to take like a
hundred Nazi policies and to turn them
into a questionnaire and ask people
either how much they agree with them
after I figured out whether they were
left or right wing to begin with or
whether they thought the policies were
representative of the left or the right
because that could be studied
empirically and I don't think anyone's
done it but that would be a very
interesting that would be a very
interesting research project